Donald Trump has been criminally
indicted for interfering with the 2020
presidential election he's alleged to
have participated in a vast conspiracy
to interfere with the election and hold
on to power yes a Federal grand jury
impaneled in Washington DC has indicted
Donald J Trump on four felony counts as
part of special counsel Jack Smith's
investigation into efforts to overturn
the 2020 presidential election as Jack
Smith said in his press conference today
an indictment was unsealed
charging Donald J Trump with felony
violations of our national security laws
as well as participating in a conspiracy
to obstruct justice so if you're
counting that makes three indictments
and 78 criminal counts in two states and
the District of Columbia Donald Trump is
the first president in U.S history to
try to interrupt the peaceful transfer
of power to his successor and the first
Home Alone 2 actor to be indicted three
separate times down the hall and to the
left so how close did the conspirators
come to succeeding and how serious did
they think it would be for Trump to
refuse to leave well according to the
indictment when a deputy White House
counsel told one of Trump's
co-conspirators Jeffrey Clark that there
would be Mass protests if Trump remained
president despite no findings of voter
fraud clerk said quote that's why we
have an Insurrection act now there was
wild speculation about what this
indictment would actually look like and
hear what the Department of Justice did
is very interesting instead of breaking
things up piecemeal they allege that all
the efforts to change or subvert the
election are part of one General
conspiracy that aimed to reverse the
election and while how the indictment
mentions the capital riots and Trump's
speech from that day none of the alleged
crimes rely on the riots or that speech
the indictment doesn't charge Trump for
inciting the January 6 riots that would
have been extremely hard to prove for
reasons that we've discussed on this
channel a lot namely that the standard
is very high and it would be very close
to charging someone for potentially
political speech but here are the riots
according to the Department of Justice's
narrative were just another opportunity
for the conspirators to delay or
overturn the election for example during
the riots the conspirators were texting
and calling Senators to try to get them
to delay certification and to pressure
Mike Pence so the riots were not an end
in themselves but a means to further the
conspiracy and this is a much cleaner
way of conceptualizing the crimes from
the doj's perspective than other ways
that they could have drafted this
indictment instead of lots of small
towers with limited foundations they
constructed one giant Tower with a huge
base or more specifically three large
conspiracies sort of operating in
parallel at the same time with generally
the same aim the first conspiracy see
was to overturn the legitimate results
of the 2020 presidential election by
using knowingly false claims of election
fraud to prevent the actual slates of
electors being collected counted and
certified the second conspiracy was to
corruptly obstruct and impede an
official proceeding that is the actual
certification of the electoral vote and
then the third conspiracy was to
effectively hamper the right of some
people to exercise their right to vote
effectively trying to discount or
prevent the votes being counted in
states where Biden won where the
conspirators were putting forth a fake
slate of electors now a quick word about
conspiracy and Free Speech many are
bemoaning the indictment as the
criminalization of political speech but
that seems to be based on a
misunderstanding of how criminal
conspiracies actually work consider this
great commentary from NYU Law Professor
Noah Rosenblum the first amendment
protects the right to free speech but
does that mean that you can say whatever
you want without facing criminal
liability not at all consider the
following two scenarios I walk into a
store and buy a crowbar no crime life is
good two I call my buddy and say let's
go buy crowbars and use them to deprive
people of the right to vote he says I
agree let's conspire to do this thing
together I walk in the store and buy a
crowbar bad news crime life is bad the
only difference between these two acts
is the fact of agreement which is
expressed in speech although it needn't
be the crime is conspiracy agreement to
commit a crime plus a step towards its
accomplishment it's not the speech
that's criminal it's what the speech
does constitute an element of another
crime here Trump is charged with
conspiracy but the lies he made about
the election are part of showing his
knowing fraud in element of the crime
don't worry you can still lie in
politics as much as you want just don't
do it as an element of another crime
like say participating in a conspiracy
to defraud people of their right to vote
and that's exactly right the only thing
that I would add is a few other
scenarios the third scenario a person
says to themselves I'm going to go out
and buy a crowbar to deprive people of
the right to vote and then I go out and
buy a crowbar still a lot of crime
because there's no conspiracy I.E an
agreement with another person then
that's important because in conspiracies
if you have an agreement all you need is
one over an act infer the rinse of the
conspiracy and in the absence of a
conspiracy the act of buying a crowbar
probably isn't enough to rise to the
level of attempted interference because
to attempt a crime by yourself usually
requires conduct that constitutes a
substantial step towards completing that
crime and then there's the fourth
scenario a person says to themselves I'm
going to buy a crowbar to deprive people
with the right to vote buys the Crowbar
and then actually starts hitting people
waiting in line to vote now still
there's no conspiracy but now you've
taken a substantial step towards the
crime and likely completed the crime and
you're guilty of that initial crime so
in the conspiracy context and actually
in many different legal contexts speech
will be relevant evidence was a
conspiracy formed what was the aim of
that conspiracy did individual members
have the requisite intent of the
underlying crime was an overt action and
furtherance of the conspiracy taken did
the defendant say factually false things
to induce others to act but here it's
not the speech that's punished it's the
conspiracy so with that in mind that
takes us to the indictment itself the
indictment starts by correctly noting
that Trump had a right to speak about
the election quote and even to claim
falsely that there had been outcome
determinative fraud during the election
and that he had won he was also entitled
to challenge the results through lawful
means such as quote seeking recounts or
audits of the popular vote in states or
filing lawsuits challenging ballots and
procedures and as the indictment notes
Trump pursued these methods but they
were uniformly unsuccessful however
Trump did not have a right to dispute
the election through quote unlawful
means of discounting legitimate votes
and subverting the election results the
indictment says that Trump perpetrated
three criminal conspiracies to stay in
office and we start with 18 USC 371.
that section criminalizes the use of
deceptive practices in connection with
any conspiracy for the purpose of
impairing obstructing or defeating the
lawful function of any Department of
government Trump is charged with
conspiring to stop Congress from
certifying the election by submitting
fake electoral slates and there are two
prongs to section 371 cases the offense
prong prohibits conspiracies to commit
acts that are otherwise defined as
criminal under federal law and the
defraud prong prohibits conspiracies to
obstruct a law lawful function of the
government by deceitful means and the
government must prove that the defendant
entered into a conspiracy with the
specific intent to defraud the United
States that the conspirators use
deceitful or dishonest means and that
one of the members of The Conspiracy
performed at least one overt act for the
purpose of carrying out the conspiracy
for the government to prove that Trump
committed the crime it must show that he
used deceit craft or trickery or
dishonest means to achieve it section
371 does not criminalize every
conspiracy to disrupt a government
function it only reaches conspiracies
that use deceit craft or trickery or
dishonest means and we'll talk about
Trump's defenses later but he's probably
going to claim that he didn't use deceit
if he truly believed that he won the
election but the indictment concludes
that Trump knew he lost and the
indictment lists all the people who told
Trump that he lost including the vice
president leaders of the doj who were
appointed by Trump the Director of
National Intelligence the director of
the Department of Homeland Securities
cyber security and infrastructure
Security Agency senior White House
officials campaign staffers Republican
state legislators and officials and
dozens of state and federal courts and
the indictment alleges that Trump
privately acknowledged his law loss
after the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff urged Trump not to take action
on a national security issue Trump
agreed saying quote yeah you're right
it's too late for us we're going to give
that to the next guy yet publicly Trump
repeatedly tweeted and encouraged his
supporters to come to Washington on
January 6 to stop the vote and allegedly
in another conversation on January 1st
2021 Mike Pence told Trump that he
didn't think that there was a
constitutional basis for Trump's claims
that the vice president lacked the
authority to change the results of the
election and quote in response the
defendant told vice president you're too
honest now this strongly implies that
Trump knew he had lost and was asking
Pence to lie and there are other
examples apparently he referred to some
of Sydney Powell's theories as crazy and
even Rudy Giuliani said quote we don't
have the evidence but we have lots of
theories but despite this it is alleged
that Trump knowingly continued to make
false claims about the election and
further took actions to subvert the
election and the indictment notes that
they might have tricked other people
into action for example the fraudulent
electors were quote tricked into
participating based on the understanding
that their votes would be used only if
the defendant succeeded in outcome to
alternative lawsuits within their state
which the defendant never did the
defendant and co-conspirators then
caused these fraudulent electors to
transmit their false certificates to the
vice president and other government
officials to be counted at the
certification proceedings on January 6
2020. now some legal commentators claim
that the government needs to prove that
the defendant intended to Swindle money
or other tangible objects from the
victim in order to be charged under
Section 371 but that's only true if
Trump was charged with a fraud crime
like wire fraud but here he wasn't the
prosecutor doesn't need to prove that
the conspiracy actually led to any
property or monetary loss by the US
government or its agencies the
department of Justice's criminal
resource manual cites a 1924 case
hammerschmed versus United States for
this proposition and in that case
Justice Taft wrote quote it is not
necessary that the government shall be
subjected to property or pecuniary loss
by the fraud but only that its
legitimate official action and purpose
shall be defeated by misrepresentation
chicane or overreaching of those charged
with carrying out the governmental
intention and several more recent cases
have affirmed that the word defraud in
section 371 quote not only reaches
Financial or property loss through the
use of a scheme or artifice to defraud
but also is designed and intended to
protect the Integrity of the United
States and its agencies programs and
policies now the second criminal charge
relates to subsection 1512 K which makes
conspiracy to violate section 1512 a
separate offense subject to the same
penalties as the underlying offense and
a 1512k charge has no specific overt act
element and the courts have generally
declined to imply one under such
circumstances now regardless of which
section is invoked conspirators are
criminally liable for any crime
committed in the foreseeable furtherance
of the conspiracy the indictment says
that Trump quote did knowingly combine
conspire Confederate and agree with
co-conspirators known to the grand jury
to corruptly obstruct and impede an
official proceeding that is the
certification of the electoral vote now
there are many examples of trump and his
co-conspirators trying to stop the
certification process and their actions
on January 6 are notable as the
indictment accuses the conspirators of
exploiting the violence at the Capitol
in furtherance of their plot after the
writers had been removed from from the
capital Trump through White House aides
attempted to reach two United States
senators at 6 PM from 6 59 PM until 7 18
PM Rudy Giuliani placed calls to five
United States senators and one United
States Representative co-conspirator 6
attempted to confirm phone numbers for
six United States senators whom
defendant had directed Giuliani to call
and attempt to enlist in further
delaying the certification quote in one
of the calls Giuliani left a voicemail
intended for a United States Senator
that said quote we need you our
Republican friends to try to just slow
it down so we can get these legislatures
to get more information to you and know
they're reconvening at eight tonight but
the only strategy we can follow is to
object to numerous States and raise
issues so that we get ourselves into
tomorrow ideally until the end of
tomorrow Trump also called another
Senator repeating false allegations of
fraud in Arizona and Georgia he also
quote claimed that the vice president's
actions had been surprising and asked
the senator to quote object to every
state and kind of spread this out a
little bit like a filibuster shortly
before the meeting to certify the
election White House counsel urged Trump
to drop his objections and allow the
meetings to proceed Trump refused the
meeting of Congress was delayed for six
hours and when it resumed at 8 pm it
certified Biden's election as president
now it's actually not weird that Trump's
co-conspirators were lawyers because
sadly finding a great lawyer is hard to
do but if you need a really good lawyer
my firm Eagle team can help if you've
been in a car crash suffered a data
breach or have a Social Security
Disability issue we can represent you or
help find you the right attorney who can
just click on the link that's in the
description for free consultation with
my team because you don't just need a
legal team you need the eagle team and
the link is down below and the Third
charge relates to 18 USC 1512 C2 Trump
was indicted for obstructing an official
proceeding of Congress now the initial
media reports about the target letter
were confusing because they reported
that Trump was being charged with
witness tampering and that's because the
short title of 18 USC 1512 is tampering
with a witness victim or informant but
here Trump wasn't charged with witness
tampering per se section 1512 covers
other kinds of obstruction of justice he
was actually charged with violating
section C2 of the statute which states
whoever corruptly obstructs influences
or impedes any official proceeding or
attempts to do so shall be fined under
this title or in prison not more than 20
years or both the section 1512c was
added to the code as part of the
sarbane's Oxley Act of 2002 and to
convict Trump under the statute the
government has to prove that he
attempted to obstruct an official
proceeding and that he acted with
corrupt intent the first element is
relatively simple for the government to
prove many of the January 6 writers were
charged with violating 1512c these
defendants argued that the January 6
meeting of Congress was not an official
proceeding but courts ruled against them
because section 1515 A1 defines official
proceeding for purposes of section 1512
to include a congressional proceeding
now the second element is whether Trump
acted with corrupt intent and some of
the January 6 defendants challenged
their indictments on the grounds that
this element is unconstitutionally vague
since the word corruptly isn't defined
by section 1512c but several circuit
courts have already rejected this
contention the courts conclude that
corruptly in 1512c includes two
component it's one intent to obstruct
impede or influence and to wrongfulness
and then count number four relates to
the deprivation of rights under color of
state law under 18 USC 241. now under
that section government official can't
deprive someone of their rights and the
statute dates from the Reconstruction
Era but it doesn't require that the
defendant's conduct be motivated by a
specific bias against the victim such as
race gender or discrimination but
section 241 makes it unlawful for two or
more persons to injure oppress threaten
or intimidate any person in any state
territory Commonwealth possession or
District in the free exercise or
enjoyment of any right or privilege
secured to him by the Constitution or
laws of the United States or because of
his having so exercise the same and here
the idea is that the conspirators
conspired to prevent people from being
able to exercise their right to vote the
offense is always a felony even if the
underlying conduct would not on its own
establish a felony violation of another
criminal civil rights statute now
critics of this indictment believe that
Trump shouldn't have been charged with
violating section 241 because this law
was passed during Reconstruction as a
way to punish members of the Ku Klux
Klan and and other people from harassing
black voters and while it's true that
this law was originally aimed at
stopping harassment of black voters
after the Civil War it is no way limited
to stopping white Confederates from
intimidation and harassment and the doj
has used this law to prosecute
conspiracies to prevent the proper
counting of ballots in federal elections
for more than 100 years the doj has
charged government officials under 241
when officials tried to stuff a ballot
box with forged ballots prevent the
official count of ballots in primary
elections destroy voter registration
applications destroy ballots exploit the
infirmities of elderly or handicapped
people by casting absentee ballots in
their names illegally registered votes
and cast absentee ballots in their names
injure threatened or intimidated voter
in the exercise of their right to vote
impersonate qualified voters fail to
count votes and to alter votes counted
to steal votes by changing the votes
cast by voters and voting machines and
the list goes on and on now many of
these alleged crimes will hinge on
Trump's mental state and we've covered
this before did Trump have a specific
intent to obstruct impede or influence
the preceding of Congress well it's
definitely possible but since this
indictment came down there have been a
lot of bad legal takes about what it
actually means especially with respect
to Trump's mental state and what the
prosecutors actually have to prove many
journalists and even some lawyers have
said that in order to convict Trump on
these charges prosecutors must prove
that Trump knew that he lost the
election see for example this headline
in the Washington Post which says the
former president's intent and whether he
knew he was lying about the election
fraud are key issues for prosecutors now
this is a big misunderstanding about
what prosecutors must prove about
Trump's mental state now look this stuff
is hard but it's not that hard now first
of all criminal prosecutors prove intent
and internal mental States all the time
it's not impossible it's not even that
hard you can do it using statements that
the defendant said you can prove it
using surrounding circumstances or in
the case of conspiracies you could even
use the statements of your
co-conspirators because in a conspiracy
you're generally liable for the acts of
your co-conspirators and the statements
of your co-conspirators are not hearsay
and second of all prosecutors have been
using the statutes under which Trump has
been charged against the January 6
protesters with great success and
Trump's potential defenses and issues
about mental states have been raised and
repeatedly rejected he's not the first
guy to claim that there was election
fraud and thus his actions were excused
now to review the doj says that Trump
intentionally participated in three
conspiracies that violate federal law
first Trump has charged with violating
section 371 that makes it illegal to
conspire to defraud her lies the United
States the meaning of defraud is
interfering or obstructing a lawful
government function by deceit craft or
trickery or dishonest means the
indictment alleges facts showing that
Trump used deceit and trickery and
dishonest means to replace the
legitimate electors with fake ones and
that's the reason for the heading on
page 27 which says quote the defendant's
attempt to leverage the justice
department to use deceit to get State
officials to replace legitimate electors
and electoral votes with defendants and
what Trump believed about the 2020
election and thus whether he lied or was
mistaken goes to the element of Deceit
in section 371 and that's arguably one
of the reasons why the indictment
contains so much information about
whether Trump lied or not in addition it
also just provides color and explanation
about his motive and if he did not
actually believe he won the 2020
election he would almost certainly have
violated section 371's prohibition
against defrauding the United States
government I.E lying to the government
but the second conspiracy is that Trump
and his co-conspirators obstructed the
January 6 Congressional proceeding where
the election would be certified in
violation of two sections of section
1512 and someone else who was charged
with this violation is January 6
defendant Alan Hostetter who is charged
with violating section 1752 C2 and 1512k
just like Trump was he tried to raise
the First Amendment defense that Trump
will rely on but a federal judge
rejected this defense explaining the
quote Mr Hostetter is not being
prosecuted for engaging in protected
First Amendment activity and I am making
my decision without regard to his
political beliefs which I believe he
holds sincerely Mr Hostetter has a right
to believe whatever he likes about the
2020 presidential election and to voice
those opinions but the First Amendment
does not give anyone a right to obstruct
or impede Congress by making it
impossible for them to do their job
safely the judge ruled that Hostetter
and his co-conspirator quote knowingly
and intentionally entered into that
agreement with the intent of furthering
its unlawful goal of disrupting and
impeding the Electoral College
certification and similarly in Trump's
situation the government need only show
that he intentionally took steps to
obstruct the Electoral College
certification so for example when the
government points to Trump's speech at
the ellipse they don't have to prove
that in his mind he knew everything he
was saying was a lie instead the speech
is evidence that he wanted to encourage
people to physically occupy the capital
and once those people were inside the
capital and the certification was
delayed Trump and his co-conspirators
continued to act in furtherance of their
conspiracy by calling Senators to
further delay the vote and Trump's
subjective belief and motive might help
explain those actions but they're not
necessary to prove the crime that he's
alleged of and the third conspiracy is
that Trump allegedly interfered with the
right to vote and to have one's vote
counted in violation of section 241 and
that section requires that the defendant
had an intent to deprive an individual
of their rights and that the federal
right violated was clearly delineated
and in a January 6 prosecution of
Douglas Mackey a jury in instruction
explained that the government had to
prove quote that the defendant knowingly
and intentionally joined the conspiracy
with the intent to further a specific
objective and the Mackie jury
instruction explains how a jury should
assess the defendant's Criminal Intent
within the context of this particular
section quote the indictment alleges
that the objective of the charged
conspiracy was to injure oppressed
threaten or intimidate one or more
persons in the free exercise and
enjoyment of their right to vote the
government must therefore approve Beyond
a reasonable doubt that the defendant
knowingly and intentionally joined the
conspiracy with the intent to further
that objective in this case the
government has alleged that the object
of the conspiracy was specifically to
injure one or more persons in the free
exercise and enjoyment of their right to
vote I instruct you that the statute
covers conduct intended to obstruct
hinder prevent frustrate make difficult
or impossible or indirectly rather than
directly assault free exercise of the
right for example hinder is defined as
to make slow or difficult the progress
of to hamper to hold back to prevent to
check and again Trump's subjective
belief about the overall election or
election fraud isn't necessary or an
element of the crime so the possible
exception of the first count Trump's
subjective belief about the 2020
election is basically irrelevant it's
his intentionality about his actions
that mattered here's how elections
lawyer Mark Elias explained it but I
walk into a bank and I think they're
wrongfully holding my money I think my
balance is 5 000 and they think my
balance is zero and I genuinely believe
that I mowed five thousand dollars that
doesn't excuse me from robbing the bank
I can't pull out a gun and take the
money particularly with the fake
collector scheme even if you believe
that you won you were not entitled to
have people submit fake forms on January
6. now the writers unsuccessfully took
down the US capital but you can
successfully get your online data taken
down with today's sponsor in cogni now I
don't know about you but I've seen a
huge uptick in the amount of spam that
I'm getting and it's no surprise why
every year the number and scope of data
breaches worldwide is rising and you
might not know it but there are hundreds
of data Brokers that possess and sell
your personal information and their
numbers grow every year these data
Brokers might have a whole Shadow
profile on you including in your name
your address phone number shopping
habits possibly even your social
security number all up for the highest
bidder at best this leads to scam calls
and at worst identity theft and doxing
but that's where incognity comes in
incognitive fights on your behalf to
remove your personal data from data
Brokers and deals with any objections
from their side all you have to do is
create an account and give them approval
to work on your behalf and cognitive
conducts repeated ongoing removals
because even if the data broker removes
your data once they can collect it again
which is just incredibly dumb but in
cognitive make sure that your personal
information stays off the market for
good and you can actually see when
incognitive does this on your personal
dashboard this is my personal dashboard
that I paid for it shows that these
three sites had data on me that was
rated 10 out of 10 on incognito's
sensitivity scale these Brokers had data
including my contacts financial data and
Health Data thankfully incognit tells me
when the removal requests are complete
so I can breathe easy now it's
terrifying to see exactly how many
Brokers have my data but it's really fun
to watch incogni get them to delete that
info one by one so if you'd like to give
incogni a try let's go in the link below
to get 60 off incognate when you use the
code legal eagle so to get an exclusive
60 off just click on the link that's on
screen right now or down in the
description and use code legal eagle
after that click on this box over here
for more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court